Mobile Task Force operatives fire their assault
rifles at the approaching crowd of SCP-008
zombies, only to be swarmed and overwhelmed.
Administrative staff try to activate the communications
arrays and contact help from another site,
but SCP-106 has melted all the wiring already,
keeping them cut off from the outside world.
Able is drawing his obsidian blades to slice
and dice some unfortunate guards, and SCP-682
is running rampant in the halls, devouring
everyone he sees.
In Site 19, thanks to the biggest containment
breach in modern records, the inmates are
now running the asylum.
The guards are no longer in control, the researchers
have no information, and the administrative
staff is powerless.
This time, the anomalies are on top.
How will our heroes at the SCP Foundation
fare when the roles are all reversed?
First, we join Dr. Clef, the most trigger-happy
researcher that the SCP Foundation ever employed
- He never met an anomaly he didn’t propose
to terminate.
Most of these anomalies, he’d be happy to
tell to their faces he wanted to terminate
them.
This was a decision he may have wanted to
go back on now that the roles were reversed,
and he found himself strapped to a table with
a number of belts.
He struggled against his restraints, but it
was no good.
He was stuck tight.
Standing above him was a D-Class possessed
by SCP-035, the Possessive Mask, carrying
one of Dr. Clef’s favorite shotguns.
A squad of cackling, vengeful members of D-Class
personnel stood behind him, egging him on.
The Possessive Mask laughed and spoke.
“Dr. Alto Clef, I have conferred with my
associates, the esteemed members of the SCP
Foundation’s D-Class personnel.
And, in light of your poor conduct, belligerent
nature, and repeated acts of excessive aggression,
we think continued containment would present
undue risks.
Instead, we recommend…
Immediate termination!”
Dr. Clef gulped, and the Possessive Mask cocked
his shotgun.
Elsewhere in the facility, SCP-076-1, Able,
the Immortal Warrior, was running some training
simulations - the exact kind that Mobile Task
Force operatives might run, but with a twist:
This time, it was Able’s training, and he
was using some captive Mobile Task Force officers
as training equipment.
He’d taken away their guns and instead given
every single one of them one of his swords
- Which, it probably goes without saying,
they weren’t quite as adept with as he was.
Not that Able cared.
When he was ready to begin his “training
simulation”, he pulled out a blade in each
hand and jumped down into the training area.
The sword-wielding MTF operatives were shaking
in their boots as he approached, the biggest,
most psychopathic smile stretched across his
face.
The second that one of the MTF operatives
made the terrible mistake of raising his sword
and running in, Able effortlessly parried
him, and the slaughter began.
By the time the “training simulation”
was done, Able was the only survivor.
And none of the MTF Operatives would later
revive themselves in a giant, black sarcophagus.
Meanwhile, SCP-682 was working on a more personal
project.
One of the SCP Foundation’s most enduring
efforts was attempting to terminate SCP-682
at all costs, using some methods that even
hardcore sadists would describe as exceptionally
cruel.
And the irreplaceable Dr. Jack Bright had
contributed more than his fair sure of potential
killing methods - Including using his anomalous
medallion to forcibly insert his consciousness
into 682’s own.
But now that the roles were reversed, 682
wanted a little of that sweet, sweet payback.
After devouring his fill of random researchers
and guards, 682 decided to narrow his focus
onto Dr. Bright.
That’s exactly why he had Dr. Bright hanging
by his arms from a pair of chains above the
same tank of acid that 682 had been wasting
away in for decades now.
682 couldn’t wait for Dr. Bright to experience
the pain he’d known for so long.
“Well, Doctor, we’ve tried burning, crushing,
and freezing, and still, it seems we can’t
give you a permanent death.
We’ll try the acid now.
I can tell you from personal experience, Doctor,
this acid is very, very effective.”
682 pulled a lever on the ground, loosening
the chains around Dr. Bright’s arms.
As the wise-cracking researcher dropped down
towards the acid, 682 felt a profound sense
of calm.
SCP-049, on the other hand, was feeling a
profound sense of excitement.
After all, he’d spent months being experimented
on by low-level research staff, after having
his own rights to research taken away after
a minor incident involving the death and subsequent
reanimation of Senior Researcher Hamlin.
And now, with the tables turned and the roles
reversed, everything was about to change.
049 had a whole gaggle of captured researchers
confined in a cell, the perfect testing stock
for his next series of experiments into the
Pestilence.
The Plague Doctor opened his bag and began
taking out each one of his frightening medical
tools, laying them across a nearby table and
ignoring the cries of protest from the cell.
He feels no pity for them - They should be
honored to become part of such a towering
body of research.
Their sacrifices would not be meaningless,
as their deaths would contribute to saving
so many other lives.
The exact same logic that the SCP Foundation
uses to justify every piece of collateral
damage that they’ve ever incurred.
But as the Plague Doctor walks towards the
cell with a scalpel, wondering which of the
terrified researchers he’d select first,
none of them really appreciated the irony.
Someone that did very much appreciate irony
was SCP-106, one of the most cruel, calculating,
and sadistic anomalies that the Foundation
has ever had to contain.
While he wasn’t nearly as talkative as some
of the other sapient humanoid anomalies out
there, he was still extremely intelligent,
and he’d been observing the methods the
SCP Foundation had been using to contain him
for all these years.
The one he found the most frustrating was
their tendency to make the area around his
containment cell extremely complicated, knowing
it would confuse him and make it that much
harder for him to escape.
SCP-106 had been planning his particular method
of role reversal for years, and little by
little, building it in his beloved pocket
dimension.
As soon as the anomalies took control of Site
19, SCP-106 captured a gaggle of researchers
and guards and dragged them to his hellish
pocket dimension.
There, he trapped each one of them inside
cells in a twisted version of Site 19.
As each one tried to escape, they found that
they were trapped in the same complex network
of obstacles that they’d always used to
keep SCP-106 contained.
The one difference is, in this case, they
were being chased by SCP-106.
And they weren’t just playing for their
freedom, they were playing for their lives.
It was the most fun SCP-106 had had in years.
But not all of the anomalies subject to the
mass Site 19 role reversal were acting out
violent revenge fantasies.
The anomalous butler, Mr. Deeds, summoned
up by the SCP-662 bell, was enjoying a real
change of pace under anomalous control.
During the early hours of the containment
breach, a researcher had rung the bell and
summoned Mr. Deeds to help them control the
chaos.
But, for some reason beyond anyone’s understanding,
Mr. Deeds had simply refused the orders.
Not because they weren’t possible, as in
the case of his usual commands, but because
today, he simply didn’t feel like it.
And if the Foundation personnel who summoned
him didn’t want him to alert more dangerous
anomalies of their presence, they needed to
wait on him for a change.
It’s not like they had any choice in the
matter this time.
That’s why Mr. Deeds was reclining in the
comfiest chair they could find, sipping on
a pina colada and getting a foot massage from
a nervous Junior Researcher.
Even the anomaly who’d devoted his entire
life to service was, on this special day,
deciding to take a load off and treat himself
to some much-needed rest and relaxation.
And who could blame him, really?
SCP-1370, on the other hand, was choosing
to make war rather than love.
Typically, this tiny, pathetic automaton known
as The Pesterbot was little more than an amusingly
useless sentient toy with delusions of grandeur.
He wasn’t an anomaly that anyone took seriously,
and even fewer people feared him.
In short, SCP-1370 was perhaps the biggest
loser in all of the Foundation’s containment.
But now that the roles had been reversed,
he wasn’t so pathetic anymore.
During the initial chaos of the containment
breach, while all the security personnel was
distracted by the significantly more dangerous
anomalies, the Pesterbot somehow managed to
sneak his way into the experimental weapons
lab.
That’s where he got his hands on a 40-watt
Phased Plasma rifle which promptly fused to
his little robot arm, allowing him to enact
a spree of chaotic shootings across his section
of the site.
He cackled in his tinny robotic voice as guards
and researchers fled from him.
He leveled his plasma rifle and fired glowing-hot
blasts in all directions, while declaring
himself to be the immutable mecha-lord of
all creation.
And when he had such a deadly tool in his
hands - One that, with a single shot, could
superheat your skeleton into radioactive ash
- Nobody dared to dispute such a claim.
Oh, how the tables had turned.
But those weren’t the only researchers in
deep trouble.
The grand role reversal had resulted in a
lot of researchers with less than ethical
scientific conduct getting a frightening taste
of their own medicine.
This is exactly what happened when a gang
of the infamous Laughing Men, SCP-2419, the
vengeful bodies of soulless D-Class personnel,
managed to get their hands on the dog-bodied
senior researcher, Dr. Kain Pathos Crow.
Dr. Crow had always been an aggressive user
of SCP-158, also known as the Soul Extractor.
Using this machine, he had ripped out the
souls of many D-Classes as part of his frowned-upon
Olympia Project.
Naturally, this role reversal would not result
in Dr. Crow getting a favorable outcome.
Instead, three Laughing Men forced him into
the Soul Extractor, which promptly removed
his soul and placed it into a jar.
A jar which the Laughing Men then decided
to play a round of catch with.
And honestly, as adorable as he may be, I
don’t think there’s any denying that Dr.
Crow had this one coming.
Maybe don’t extract so many people’s souls
next time, Doctor.
But for some anomalies, the role reversal
was not a time for relaxation, rampaging,
or revenge.
It was a time for personal development.
This was the case for SCP-2430, the Immortal
Hitler Clone.
With all the chaos that was going on, the
daily staff Hitler-punching roster had fallen
by the wayside, allowing the anomalous ex-dictator
to leave his cell for once and wander around
the facility.
Eventually, he found himself in a room he’d
never been in before: The Site 19 employee
library, which featured a wide range of both
anomalous and non-anomalous texts.
This was where he found and decided, out of
sheer curiosity, to read a variety of personal
development and antiracism books that taught
him the error of his ways.
For the first time, and in what was perhaps
the biggest role reversal of the entire breach,
he began to realize that the philosophy of
discrimination he’d held in his previous
life had hurt hundreds of millions of people,
and put him on the road to nowhere.
But before he could go any further down the
road of self-development, the long-awaited
cavalry arrived.
The fact that Site 19 had dropped out of contact
with other nearby sites for over ten hours
had raised alarm bells with the O5 Council,
who’d dispatched a wide array of Mobile
Task Forces to save the terrorized populace
of Site 19 and return Foundation control.
All of the day’s role reversals were re-reversed
back into their original state.
That’s right: Everything had been returned
to normal.
For now, anyway…
Now go check out “Rick and Morty More Powerful
Than SCP Foundation?
Mad Scientist Battle!” and “SCP-343 God
Vs Bill Cipher From Gravity Falls” for more!